- So today we're gonna be trying
a really delicious ice
cream treat called Taiyaki,
and I've brought some friends.
- Hi!
- Hello, what up?
- Salorme and Emily, here.
And we're gonna get on the road
and see what this thing is like.
(upbeat music)
- [Host] Taiyaki is a Japanese sweet treat
that looks like a type of
fish called the sea bream.
It usually consists of
pancake or waffle batter,
and is filled with red bean paste.
In recent years some versions have evolved
to include delicious, delicious ice cream.
The treat has been enjoyed by the people
of Japan for over a century,
so, we had to try it too.
You told me ice cream is
your favorite dessert.
- Could you say that again?
I feel like I was doing this to my face
while you were talking.
- That's fucking unbelievable.
(beep)
- I like eclairs, too.
But I guess isn't that
technically ice cream?
- Eclairs are not ice cream.
- No, they're like the ones
that are in the freezer.
- She's talking about the
chocolate eclair ice cream bar.
- [Salorme] Okay, so yes, Ice cream.
Yup, I like ice cream.
- What we're gonna eat
today is called Taiyaki.
- Oh.
- Do you know what that is?
- No, I just said oh because
I don't know what it is.
- How's my driving.
- It's okay.
We haven't died.
- Okay.
- It's ice cream time.
- I'm so excited.
I can't wait.
- [Emily] This is so beautiful.
- [Host] Did you expect it to be a fish?
- No.
This is so cool.
I don't know if you can see it,
but it's like this little
fish shaped cookie,
and inside they stuffed it with Nutella.
I got ube and black sesame.
With sprinkles.
- Okay, so I got the same flavor as Emily
because I'm basic, but whatever.
It tastes good.
Don't judge me.
- Um, I got ube and I got red bean,
which is kind of the
classic Taiyaki filling.
- Oh my god, that is so good.
- Why isn't all food delivered to us
in a delightful, animal shaped package.
- I'm really glad we came.
- It's like, sweet and a little savory.
Yeah.
But like, very very subtle.
- Red bean is kind of sweet.
Not too sweet.
I really like these flavors
because they're not overwhelming.
Look at what I'm getting
all over my hands.
- Oh my god, this is like a waffle.
Dude, no cone can match up to this.
- Get this thing.
This thingamajigger.
- I think we ate it the wrong
way because I saw everyone
else eating it with a spoon.
- I felt like I was stuffing it in my face
so I could get to the fish part.
- Yeah.
- I just wanted that sweet fish meat.
- You know, I think maybe
a waffle cone provides
a little more structure,
but it doesn't provide
as much fun as the fish cone does.
- 'Cause its like having a
soft taco versus a hard taco.
- Oh my god.
- Everybody knows that soft taco,
soft taco always trumps a hard taco.
- Right.
- They weren't so rich, they were like,
very nice flavors all
blended together really well.
- Yeah it just sorta like...
- A wah wah!
(beep)
- So I guess you know,
if this is something
that you can get in your
town, I definitely recommend,
getting it.
- Are you guys doing
anything fun this weekend?
- No.
(drum music)